this is Garth Eric I'm a professor of
microbiology and immunology at Drexel
University College of Medicine where I
also direct the center for genomic
sciences and the Center for advanced
microbial processing today I'm going to
talk about the development of machine
learning algorithms to data mind can
genomic characterization of complex
bacterial species I'm going to start
with a discussion of chronic bacterial
infections which I've been studying for
about 25 years and I was at the very
happy nexus of clinical and
microbiological events which led us to
understand in 1996 that it was likely
that chronic bacterial infections were
associated with bacteria adapting the
biofilm mode of growth and this is an
image of bacterial biofilms growing on
the middle ear mucosa of the chinchilla
subsequently we showed that biofilms do
in fact cause chronic infections in
humans this is a streptococcus
pneumoniae biofilm growing on the middle
ear mucosa of a child who has potatoes
media or middle ear disease that has
failed numerous courses of antibiotics
so you might ask what role does biofilm
play in getting to machine learning well
biofilms and what we call a population
level burial inspector in a population
level very balanced factor is a disease
associated in mechanism that exists
stur occurs only at the population level
it is not the trade of an individual
bacteria but rather a trait that's
associated with bacterial
multicellularity and most these
population level virulence factors are
associated with chronicity or
persistence as opposed to acute prions
treat such as toxin production so one of
the reasons that we were interested in
biofilms is because biofilms potentiate
other population level Aran's factors
including horizontal gene transfer
so the biofilm brings bacteria in close
proximity to other bacteria so here we
have two different bacteria and the
biofilm that provides a stable
environment for mating which allows the
passing of a genetic trait from one
bacteria to another forming essentially
a third bacteria now it also provides
the matrix for maintaining DNA in close
proximity of bacterial cells for
competence and transformation which is a
second type of horizontal gene transfer
to bacteria under job so once we
understood that bacteria in a biofilm
were using multiple population level
virulence traits and we knew that
horizontal gene transfer was operational
this led to my development of what would
call the distributed genome hypothesis
about twenty years ago and the
distributed genome hypothesis states
that chronic bacterial pathogens utilize
a survival strategy
wherein a majority of their genes are
distributed among a population or a
species
our net found in all members of that
species thus there exists a super genome
other people they are called a pan
genome at the population level which is
far greater in size in the genome of any
one organism and we have Imperial ins
corollary to the distributed genome
hypothesis which states that this
distribution of genes among a population
serves as a super virulence factor or a
population of over here let's factor
that provides her improved population
survival through continual horizontal
gene transfer mechanisms which provides
for rapid adaptation to environmental
conditions through the reassortment of
genes as well as the wheels well it's
important to talk about here that we're
talking about truly the reassortment of
genes in most cases and not now and not
just the wheels so on this next slide is
a cartoon moon how we view a population
based super genome or pan genome so if
each of the individual blue ellipses
which has a green helix in it represents
a strain of bacteria and the green helix
represents the core genome that is the
genes that are common amol strains of
that population or species what we now
see is that if we look at the entire
genome of each individual strain within
that species that it has a set of
distributed genes indicated by a
different colored helix and so you can
see that all all strains are made up of
a core genome and are distributed genome
or an accessory genome and if one of
these strains dies the DNA goes back
into the matrix of the biofilm and then
can be picked up by one of the
constrains forming yellow reforming yet
another strain and so this is the
concept of this super virulence factor
that the host is passed that we dealing
with the evolution of new strains
through horizontal transfer mechanisms
and this is supported by the fact that
if you look with any microbial species
there was no in genomic diversity
each strainer isolate within a species
had its own unique set of genes derived
from its population level super to know
the extent of this obviously was not
knowing but it was known that there were
some genic differences among strains
so the problem became how do we
characterize this genetic plasticity and
determine relationships among strains of
a species so with these thoughts in mind
we developed a strategy to comparatively
analyze the genomic characters of large
numbers of strains of several pathogens
and what this really was was the
development of next-generation
sequencing so initially we partnered
with 454 Life Sciences as their original
academic alpha tester which allowed us
then to be able to sequence large
numbers of genomes of multiple bacterial
species which was something it was not
feasible prior to the development of
next-gen sequencing and so we chose a
number of different bacterial species to
look at here where you see Thermopolis
influenza streptococcus pneumoniae
Staphylococcus aureus Pseudomonas
aeruginosa and gardnerella vaginalis and
we chose these our original group
because it included gram positives gram
negative gram any determinants but we
turn professional pathogens as they live
nowhere except in the human body such as
him off listen
the lens and Streptococcus pneumoniae
and then opportunistic pathogens such as
soon emotive surgeon Elsa and
Staphylococcus aureus because we wanted
to know when we were trying to test the
disputed genome I pathes whether it was
you know the universal or not and so as
we started sequencing individual genomes
of homoplasy influenza we plotted the
total number of genes on the top here so
that on the beat with the blue diamonds
and we also plotted the number of genes
that were core that is that were present
in every spring of the species and so
what you can see is that the core genome
very rapidly reaches an asymptote around
1,400 genes but the super genomic an
genome just continues to increase in
size it's so we were interested in is we
could actually model this and so Justin
Hope who was a mathematician in my group
at the time actually developed what he
called the finite super genome model and
this is a graphical representation for
Thermopolis influenza here and so you
can see that it hung off was up once
you'd expect to have about 3,000 genes
you've got 24 genomes based on his
modeling and so what we found was that
as we increased the number of genes up
to 24 his model is actually pretty much
right out we were right at 3,000 genes
when we had sequence 24 independent
isolates and so it was very interesting
is when we've looked at the genomes of
each of these strains we found really
enormous differences in the size of the
genomes the smallest genome had only
1688 genes whereas the largest genome
had 967 genes right
the same species but you've got one
strain which has 300 more genes out of
very small genomes than another string
does we can also look at the number of
unique genes that are in each strain and
with only a couple exceptions every
strain has a fairly large number of
unique genes so this one has 60 genes
and none of the other strains have this
one has 31 now that none of the other
strains have assuming that we can look
at the percent of non core genes or
distributed clusters in each genome and
we see it varies from 16 to 28 percent
on an individual genome basis so on
average what we found was that each
strain differs at 18% of its lowest i or
80% of its genes with respect to every
other strain and this has very profound
implications in terms of strain specific
differences with respective disease
phenotype pathogenicity so once you
start realizing that you have this
enormous diversity in gene content you
can actually start looking at parameters
that no one ever thought to look at
before and so we developed a number of
parameters including the similarity
score which is the total number of gene
clusters shared between a pair the
different score which is the total
number being clusters not shared between
affair unique share that is the toner
gene cluster shared only within that
pairing and then a composite score
comparison score the team by subtracting
a different score from the similarity
score so in this next slide I just draw
your attention to the average difference
so if you're looking here at all
possible strain pairs for him off with
simple Enza that we had sequence at this
point on average every strain pair
differed from every other strip ever
excuse me every strain different from
every other string
by an average of 378 gene possessions
which is truly remarkable when you see
that the average size of the genome is
somewhere out between 1700 and 1800
genes and so even with just two dozen
genes sequence we can see that the core
genome is smaller than the distributed
genome so the core genome makes up 47
percent and the distributed genome makes
up 53% of Pangea or the super genome and
all that distributed genome set 17% are
unique that are found in only one string
we got very similar results when we
looked at pneumococcus or skeptic caucus
pneumonia we see the core genome
plateaus at about 1,500 genes but the
super genome just continues to increase
in size and we sequence more strange
so Justin used is finite super genome
model actually to predict how many
strains we would need to sequence to get
various coverage levels at various gene
frequencies so for looking only at non
rare genes that is genes that are
present in at least 10% of the strains
there is 90% coverage of the super
genome
we'd only have to sequence 11 strains
you get 95% coverage of non rare genes
we have to sequence 17 string and to get
99% coverage of nine routines we'd have
to sequence 33 strings but if we wanted
to give just 90% coverage of all
population frequencies that would
include rare genes that are present less
than 10% we have to sequence a hundred
and forty-two strings and then he also
used his mathematical model to predict
that the overall size of the super
genome with over 5,000 genes even though
no one strain has more than eighteen or
nineteen hundred genes
so in this case the super genome is
three times the size of the core genome
so thus essentially providing proof that
distributed genome hypothesis where we
said the majority of genes would be
distributed and so without going through
in detail all the bacterial species we
looked at we can now say the distributed
genome hypothesis holds for every
bacterial species examine all bacterial
species possess a super genome and this
is just tabular data for 24 different
bacterial species and you can see that
independent of Gram stain low GC to high
GC large genome size or small genome
size if we look just down here in the
bottom which is an average across all
species that 22% of the genes in every
strain of every species that we look at
are distributed so we conclude finally
that the distributed genome hypothesis
holds for all bacterial examined the
core genomes and all species are smaller
than distributed genomes with one
exception that's tuberculosis
thus the super genomes are model to be
multiple times the size of core genomes
and the observed genomic plasticity
provides a plausible means to understand
the phenotypic diversity among clinical
strains of a species so once we knew
that there were large numbers of
distributed genes and that they
obviously played a role in ambulance and
pathogenicity we wanted to characterize
novel variant with determinants within
the NPH i superb you know and we thought
that the way to do this would be using
statistical genetics because the vast
majority of genes even today
for any bacterial species are either
unattended or under annotated if you
will and so our strategy was to sequence
a large number of n thi strains
including commensal strains that is
those that are not associated disease
and virulent strains those that were
associated with disease and then group
the genes from all these sequence
strains into ornithologist clusters and
then determine the completeness of the
super genome using our finite Silverdale
model and then build from that super
genome hybridization array which would
contain all this distributed genes and
then perform gene phenotype statistical
Association studies using this species
specific server jo-jo so essentially we
would interrogate large numbers of
strange and then obtain sets of disease
related cogs and so that's exactly what
we did we started with 24 sequence
genomes and blast annotated all the cogs
to identify gene families and then used
that to build an array and then screened
over 200 him offal symbol in two screens
strains strains on the array and what we
found were that there were a large
number of strains that contained mu
equals this SLR a SLR life domains and
so we look at the statistics of this we
just used Fisher's exact test comparing
the presence of this be these be SLR
strains there's SLR genes in virulent
versus commensal strains and got a
p-value of about point zero two and so
this was the first example you could use
unbiased means and this
statistical genetics to identify a
presumptive virulence gene just based on
its differential possession within the
species and so then I had two graduate
students who then worked to determine
whether these bhi SLE are proteins that
were predicted from this from this from
this Dean family actually played a role
in Demopoulos influenza pathogenesis
it's one of the first things that they
did was to knock out all four copies of
this gene in a virulent strain of from
AAPIs influenza that we call fit III and
replace it with a can of mice and
cassette as you can see in this slide
here and what we showed was that the
knockout had greatly decreased Fitness
in in vitro biofilms so if this be on
the y axis here is competitive and index
and on the x axis is days following yet
to start the experiment and so if the
knockout was equal to the wild-type then
you would expect to see a straight line
at a competitive index of one and what
we see here is that by day two the
wild-type has a great advantage over the
nack order the knockout is essentially
doing very very poorly and it continues
to decrease in prevalence within the
biofilm out to day six
so this at least indicated you know that
under
anaerobic conditions because biofilms
tend to be anaerobic
that this knock out was at a
disadvantage and so then we did similar
experiments except in vivo so we use the
chinchilla object as a model for middle
ear disease or otitis media and we put
both the wild type and the knockout
bacteria mixed it a ratio one to one
into the chinchillas middle ear and then
over time sampled and look to determine
whether there was a competitive index or
for the wild type versus the knockout
and what you can see this is by animal
so we had six different animals here and
the competitive index again on the
y-axis just like we did in in vitro
biofilms shows that for all of the
specimens that we sampled whether it was
the actual tympanic membrane or the
effusion that was in the year that there
was a great competitive advantage for
the wild-type over the knockout in this
animal model of otitis media which have
been validated as being a very
representative of human disease so again
more evidence now in vivo evidence that
this being this B is LR gene is
important in pathogens do so at this
point we could conclude that the
wild-type had a fitness advantage over
the knockout in colon fraction studies
and that we thought that was associated
actually with infection in the brain
because we could recover the wild-type
from the frame booth to never recover
the knockout from the brain
as I said the wild-type also had the
fitness advantage in vitro biofilms but
Matt planktonic cultures
so all this supported the concept that
it was probably associated with being
able to deal with enter or biases we did
a complementation experiment where we
put one copy of the VA VI SLR back in
and it partially restored the wild-type
phenotype for local disease but we still
didn't see any in the brain remember the
parent has four copies of the disease so
that we conclude that there's a copy
number effect based on this the
difference between the single compliment
and the wild-type so what was the
mechanism by which this gene or protein
provided for increased survival in a
competitive environment so he looking at
related proteins in other bacteria we
suspected that it might allow for
survival in macrophages and so we did an
in vitro macrophage uptaken survival
experiment and here you can see exactly
what's going on so the wild type strain
which is in the dark blue enters and
persists for at least three days in the
macrophages where is in the knockout
represented by the red line all all of
the knockout bacteria are dead inside
the America prizes within 24 hours and
then we can show that the complement
behaves like the wild-type as well
interestingly if you take a strain
Kamala's that does not help with the H
is LR which is this strain Rd you can
see that it also dies within 24 hours
when out taken by macrophages as shown
by the green line here but if we knock
in the VH is LR gene into this strain
then it behaves somewhat more like the
earthy the virulent strain with the
bacteria persisting at least for two
days so we can conclude that the VH is
LR plays a role in macro fire survival
and in in in multiple strains and I as
well as affecting its ability of biochem
growth we also showed it provides
enhanced found serum resistance so we
mean this protein now that macrophage
survival factor and so I went through
this demonstration of characterizing an
annotated protein because I want you to
understand that not only can we use you
know this unbiased method in this case a
statistical method to identify it
candidate virulence gene but when you
test the candidate very early stage it
actually plays a role in virulence so as
we have continued with our work in
sequencing large numbers of bacteria
within the homoplasy influenza two of
the computer programmers actually three
of the computer programmers I mean my
team and my Chairman's team have now
been using machine learning technologies
which are statistical methods but
they're very
beep statistical methods if you will and
you're able to pull much more
information out with these deep learning
methods you can just using the simple
Fisher's exact test sort of students
t-test as we did with the initial
studies so just to reiterate Home Office
influenza which is our general bacterial
guinea pig he is a nationally competent
species it has molecular machinery that
allows it to uptake exogenous DNA from
its environment and then it can
recombine that DNA into its genome and
so if you look at the phylogenetic
relationships the you not necessary
flecked type because of horizontal gene
transfer so the image on the right hand
side here you can see what happens when
you get horizontal gene transfer you
would not expect be to have the trait
that it does if you're simply using
phylogenetics but it's picked a trade up
by a horizontal gene transfer down from
c and so again you know by looking at
gene possession versus some sort of
identifiable phenotype it is possible to
identify genes that are associated with
that phenotype so now instead of working
with a couple hundred genes we're now
working with over a thousand genomes
characterized both by the disease they
caused and a tissue body site from which
they were recovered
and so we have these strange genes
annotated or at least proved into cogs
excuse me and then what we did is after
we've done all the clustering we decide
to look at the distributed genes which
are not rare that is present in 10% or
more of all strings and also not the
ones that are near core so basically
we're looking at distributed genes that
are present between and and 90% of
strains we're removing the extremes and
you can see down below that we have
grouped them by location of isolation
and by disease and so my location of
isolation
we've got muscle and the cerebral spinal
fluid in here and I lower respiratory
and upper respiratory joint space and
unknown and then by disease we have it
by carriage so these are commensal by
COPD chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease conjunctivitis meningitis otitis
media and other and so if you look at
phylogenetic trees and then try to put
gene presence or absence on top of this
in terms of looking at location of
isolation or disease of isolation you
see this just a complete scatter plot
and so it's very very it would be very
very difficult you know using phylogeny
you'd be able to pull this out
and so this is just a slide showing the
filtering that we use to get rid of the
bottom 10% and the top 10% so we started
with 4207 jeans and we filter out the
ones that are very rare which is a large
number as you can see on the left hand
slide and we sequence out the cool-blue
the core jeans which is also a fairly
large group and so we're left with 769
jeans as features which we then used in
two different machine learning
algorithms as input each gene feature is
affected by their 1 or 0 representing
it's the presence or absence of that
particular string so when you use two
different methods we use neural networks
and random forests and then use gene
presence or absence to do do training
and so the way it worked was we trained
the algorithms on 80% of the strains
holding back 20% to then test and we did
five fold cross validation z' repeat
everything twice all analysis reform
performed in are using the caret package
and so using the neural Nets we didn't
we got better than you would expect just
based on random because we're looking at
here five different dozen use or disease
phenotypes
we've got carriage COPD conjunctivitis
meningitis and otitis media so anything
over 20% is is better than you know
better than just random but it wasn't
extraordinaire we got a maximum of 45
percent or 46 percent
using this neural network approach using
a random forest approach based on body
sight we're able to get an accuracy of
56 percent so that's almost three times
better than just random guessing and
almost the same accuracy for disease
type by parameter tuning tour of the
random tourist where we looked at the
number of layers of trees if you roll
that is how deep the forest is we
started with 98 and then saw that that
did the best over a very broad grouping
and so look in the space around that
from 88 to 108 and found that 88 did the
best from that and so we said our case
or worse still a kind of at the high end
here so we dropped down and looked at
another group of trees from 68 to 88
which gave us the best of 81 this is for
the body sight and we hit an analogous
type of tuning for disease and ended up
with 47 layers of trees being the best
for that and so then if we take a look
at the actual results we got following
this parameter tuning we see that it
didn't make a huge difference for the
body sight he went from 56 to 58 percent
but it really helped the disease and so
we are now at or 85 percent accuracy for
the disease call College of disneys and
for some of the diseases like COPD we're
actually as high as 94 percent accurate
again for meningitis 90 percent accurate
are really our biggest issue was being
able to
carriage and otitis media and this isn't
that surprising because when you get our
tightest media the strains in ITEX we
attend to overrun the nasal pharynx
which is where we sample the carriage
from so we are pretty happy about it
this accuracy of this disease tune a
random forest model and so then we
actually use that to go back and look
and see what the program was using as
the most predictive classifiers and this
is where it got really pretty exciting
for someone like me who's interested in
things that we don't know anything about
so that's why I call it a window into
the genomic dark matter because if you
look at the table on the right you'll
see the four of the top five genes
encode hypothetical proteins that means
we have no idea what these genes are
encoding that means that it's very
likely that there's huge amounts of new
biology that we will learn by
characterizing you know the genes and
proteins that this classifier has
identified as being most important in
determining what disease is a the
homoplasy influenza is causing we're
also using neural nets in a different
way to begin annotation of these random
forest to find classifier teams and this
is work is being done by will vampyre
and my chairman Brian Wiig dogs group in
collaboration with josh hurl and my
group who was one of the people
developed developed the random forest
methods and so working with another
middle ear pathogen or odo pathogen
called mark salad
Corrales which is Josh's organism of
study they started with 13,000 692
hypothetical proteins from the Mark
Seliger Alice super genome and using a
very restrictive cutoff point a there's
80% probability that the neuron that was
going to get it right they got at least
one go term goes gene ontology terms for
1920 of these hypothetical proteins or
for 14% and using a less restrictive
cutoff a big person proposed 50%
accuracy they really get at least one go
term assignment for twice as many genes
28% of that total so we now have
multiple machine learning tools that
were using in tandem to both identify uh
Nana tative genes and then start to give
us clues as to what the annotations of
those genes might be and I write or it's
you know stress that this is all done
you know just starting from pan genome
or Superdome characterizations of large
numbers of strains for which we have
clinical provenance so I want to thank
several individuals fan who on the
science side who worked with me on the
development of the distributed genome
hypothesis and the concept of population
level theory on straights and really
developing next-gen sequencing and the
clinical side I want to thank Chris post
it was my clinical partner for 20 years
the knee mt surgeon who brought the
model of middle ear disease to us and
from which all the work I talked about
today from starting with the biofilms a
man
and finally I want to thank bill Koster
10 the father of biofilm biology for
inspiration and support you know when I
first developed the spirit of genome
hypothesis
I almost got laughed off the planet but
bill was a big believer in it and told
me to keep pursuing it next I want to
thank the team at Asri my previous
institution who developed a lot of the
original tools that I talked about today
Justin Hogue is the mathematician who
developed the super genome model Josh
are always still with me and was the one
who's developing all the machine
learning tools that we're doing here
Louisa Hillier who did a lot of the
pneumococcal work Ben Gento was one of
the graduate students who characterized
the MSF and that revived survival factor
was that a med who was my genomics lab
manager and several other people in the
bioinformatics team and then my current
team at Drexel University the lab team
actually do all the sequencing and a
bioinformatics again we see Josh RL and
Rachel they're like no relation to
myself are the ones who have been
developing the random forest models as
well as a Josh now an Archon spot so
thank you and I'll be happy if you email
me questions to respond as I have time